- By now, you've probably heard about
the terrible acts of Ethan Crumbley
on November 30th, 2021
at Oxford High School.
It's the latest in a long string
of school shootings in America.
But what is legally interesting
about this case is that,
in addition to filing murder charges
against Ethan Crumbley,
Oakland County Prosecutor Karen McDonald
decided to charge his parents,
James and Jennifer Crumbley,
with involuntary manslaughter.
With this decision,
McDonald broke with other prosecutors
who have in the past declined
to charge parents
for the acts of a child.
So the question is
what if anything is different
about this particular case
and does it signal a trend towards
making parents more responsible
for school shootings?
As is often the case these days,
many people are misunderstanding
the charges that were levied
against James and Jennifer Crumbley.
Here, these charges hinge
on a difficult legal question.
Could they have reasonably foreseen
that their teenage son
would use the gun they
purchased to kill people?
Did they willfully disregard
the results to others
that might follow
from their action or failure to act?
And here, the prosecutor is arguing
that the answer is yes.
They knowingly armed a child
who had serious emotional problems.
And when they were warned
that he was searching for ammunition
and had drawn a violent scene
involving someone being shot,
they didn't search Ethan's backpack
or take him home.
The defense lawyers
will likely argue the answer is no.
The parents locked up their gun,
consulted with the school officials,
and everyone reached the same conclusion
that there was no risk that their son
would take a gun out and shoot people,
which is why he was sent back to class.
Now, millions of parents,
and by proxy their children,
are armed in America.
And I'm sure the Crumbleys will argue
that they had no way to know
that this case would have been different
from all of the other millions of cases
that do not result
in intentional homicide.
Here, Oakland County
filed involuntary manslaughter charges
against Jennifer and James Crumbley,
accusing them of failing to intervene
on the day that their
son killed four people,
despite being confronted
twice by the school
about their son's interest in weapons.
According to the
prosecutor on Black Friday,
15-year-old Ethan went to his father James
to purchase a nine millimeter SIG Sauer
from the Acme Shooting Goods.
Ethan posted a photograph
of the new gun on his social media
later that day.
The post said, "My new beauty,"
with a heart emoji.
Jennifer Crumbley posted that the gun
was a Christmas present for Ethan.
And they had enjoyed a mother-son day
at the range.
On the following Monday, November 29th,
one day before the shooting,
a teacher said that she saw
a boy searching online for ammunition,
which prompted a meeting
with school officials.
The school left a voicemail
and sent an email,
but Jennifer did not
respond to the school.
However, Mrs. Crumbley
texted her son, quote, "LOL!
"I'm not mad at you.
"You have to learn not to get caught."
On Tuesday morning, November 29th,
the teacher found a
worksheet on Ethan's desk
and took a photo.
It was a drawing of a gun
pointing at the words,
"The thoughts won't stop.
"Help me."
There was also a drawing of a bullet
with words above it,
"Blood everywhere."
There was a person between
the gun and the bullet.
The person appears to
have been shot twice.
Ethan allegedly wrote,
"My life is useless."
The teacher contacted the Dean of Students
and the School Counselor.
They called the Crumbleys
for an emergency meeting at the school.
Meanwhile, Ethan was placed
in the counseling room
with his backpack.
The counselor obtained the drawing,
but Ethan had already
scratched out portions.
He allegedly said the drawing
was part of a video game
that he was designing,
that he wanted a career
as a video game designer.
Ethan stayed in the office
for approximately 90 minutes
working on his science assignment.
According to the Superintendent,
the counselor didn't believe
that he would harm others
based on his behavior or his demeanor.
The Crumbleys arrived to
the school around 10:30 a.m.
School officials showed
James and Jennifer the note.
They asked Ethan whether
he wanted to harm himself or others.
And based on his answers,
the parents and school officials
assumed that he was not a threat.
The Crumbleys resisted the idea
of their son leaving the school
and returning to an empty house.
The school told the parents
to get Ethan into
counseling within 48 hours.
According to Superintendent Tim Thorne,
the school permitted Ethan
to return to class
because he had no disciplinary history.
At about 12:51 p.m.,
Ethan Crumbley emerged
from a school bathroom
with the gun his father
bought him four days before.
He fired at students in the hallway,
killing four,
and wounding six students and one teacher.
After the shooting made the news,
Jennifer texted Ethan
Crumbley at 1:22 p.m.,
quote, "Ethan, don't do it!"
Just 15 minutes later,
James calls 911 to report a gun
was missing from his house
and he believed his son
might be the shooter.
The Crumbleys said that the gun
had been kept in a locked drawer
in the parents' bedroom.
So one of the things
that's interesting here
is that the parents are not being charged
by virtue of being parents,
but rather because of the actions
they took in general.
It's not a case of charging the parents
for what the child did.
In other words,
the argument is that
if anyone took the alleged actions
that the Crumbleys took,
they could be charged with the same thing,
regardless of whether
they were the parents or not.
Now to understand this distinction
and understand what is
happening in this case,
we need to talk about the different kinds
of homicide in Michigan.
So first we start with murder.
First degree murder is defined
as a killing "perpetrated
by means of poison,
"lying in wait,
"or any other willful, deliberate,
"and premeditated killing."
Premeditated means the person
thought about committing the murder
before the act.
This can take place weeks
or months ahead of time,
or it can take place
one second beforehand.
For example, a Michigan
man named Kierelle Burns
was convicted of first degree murder
after he made up a story
about a robbery to lure his friend
into an alley
where he purposefully shot and killed him.
Burns said that he was acting
on the orders of a business associate,
but he still created a plan
for the murder ahead of time.
And this is a classic
example of premeditation.
And although the Burns case
is what most people think about
when they hear the words premeditation,
the term also applies
when someone quickly makes up their mind
to kill someone,
often in a split second.
And here, Ethan Crumbley is charged
with four counts of first degree murder
and several counts of attempted murder.
So, no surprise there.
Then we get to manslaughter.
In contrast, manslaughter
is murder without malice.
Manslaughter offenses
are not premeditated.
Manslaughter is generally defined
as the crime of killing a human being
without malice of forethought,
or otherwise in circumstances
not accounting to murder.
Michigan's criminal statutes
do not give a precise
definition of manslaughter.
As a result, Michigan courts look
to the common law
to define traditional
categories of manslaughter.
That is voluntary manslaughter
and involuntary manslaughter.
In Michigan, voluntary manslaughter
is often a heat of passion crime.
It differs from first degree murder
because the intent to kill was formed
when the defendant had a sudden violent
and irresistible passion
caused by some sort of provocation.
This provocation or excitement
has to happen almost immediately
without the chance
for the person to cool down.
And if the person had enough time
to get their emotions under control
and they still decide
to kill another person,
then that is actual murder.
Now, involuntary manslaughter
occurs during an accidental
or non-intentional death
where the defendant had no intent
to cause someone else's death,
but their reckless act
winds up resulting in death.
Involuntary manslaughter can also happen
during an unlawful act.
That is, a misdemeanor
or low-level felony like a DUI.
Perhaps the most classic example
of involuntary manslaughter
is when someone is drunk
and gets behind the wheel,
and then kills another person
in a car accident.
Since everyone is presumed
to know that driving while under
the influence of alcohol or drugs
is reckless and puts others in danger,
the resulting fatality is often charged
as involuntary manslaughter.
Now, other reckless acts or omissions
can lead to criminal charges too.
For example, if you decided to blow up
a giant firework in a crowded space,
and someone is hit and killed,
that would probably be
involuntary manslaughter too.
Potentially something even more serious.
You might not have meant
to kill a certain person in the crowd,
but since it's so dangerous
to engage in that activity,
you would probably be charged
with involuntary manslaughter.
Now under Michigan law,
to convict someone of
involuntary manslaughter,
a prosecutor must prove
beyond a reasonable doubt
that the defendant
caused the death of the victim.
That in doing the act
that caused the victim's death,
the defendant acted in
a grossly negligent manner.
And that the defendant caused the death
without lawful excuse or justification.
Now, proving someone
else's acts or omissions
actually caused someone else's death
is not an easy task,
especially when the people
who were charged
didn't commit the physical acts
that led to the death.
So in this case,
that means the prosecution
has to prove that Ethan Crumbley's
intentional acts did not break
the chain of causation that started
when the parents purchased the gun.
The jury instruction
on causation explains,
"It is not enough that the defendant's act
"made it possible for the death to occur.
"In order to find that the death
"was caused by the defendant,
"you must find beyond a reasonable doubt
"that the death was the natural
"and necessary result
of the defendant's act."
Now here, the prosecutor can show
that the son easily obtained the gun
as a direct result of
the parent's actions,
but that's not nearly enough.
The prosecutor will probably
also make the case that the Crumbleys
failed to secure the weapon.
That the weapon wasn't locked up
or if it was,
it wasn't properly secured.
And their son had easy access to the gun.
But in the Crumbley's defense,
their lawyers will probably argue
that the school didn't warn the parents
he had threatened to use a firearm.
That their complaint was only
that he had made a drawing
with violent imagery
including a firearm,
which probably millions of young boys
are doing every single day.
And while he was arguably
fantasizing about killing,
the school and the parents
concluded that he wasn't a threat
to himself or others.
And Ethan's internet search for ammo
was just that, a search.
And of course, there
are many legal reasons
to use ammunition in a gun.
I'm sure they'll argue that
given the short history
of the whole family
going to the shooting range,
that the most likely conclusion
is that Ethan Crumbley was searching
for ammunition to use at the range
as they had done in the past.
And on top of that,
to prove the crime of
involuntary manslaughter,
the state has to prove that the Crumbleys
acted with gross negligence,
not simple negligence
where you act unreasonably.
But gross negligence means
more than carelessness.
It means willfully disregarding
the results to others
that might follow
from an act or failure to act.
The prosecution must also prove
that to a reasonable person,
it would have been apparent
that the result was likely to be
serious injury to another person.
And this is a very difficult case.
Just because the Crumbleys
didn't act as another person might,
doesn't necessarily mean
that they acted with gross negligence.
And assuming that the Crumbleys
did not lock up their gun,
would that itself
constitute gross negligence?
Well, in many states,
it is a crime to not
properly store a firearm
when there is a child in the home.
But Michigan does not have any
Child Access Prevention Laws.
That doesn't mean it's,
per se, unlawful for the Crumbleys
to carelessly store their firearms.
And of course, the Crumbleys
do not admit that they were negligent
in storing their gun and ammunition.
And of course, not
searching Ethan Crumbley's
backpack under these circumstances
is also a point of contention.
I'm sure the prosecution will argue
that failing to search the backpack
was also grossly negligent.
But under these circumstances,
the Crumbleys allegedly didn't find out
that their gun was missing
until after the school shooting
had already started.
And of course, the school didn't
search the backpack either.
Though there is one other issue
that may hurt the Crumbleys's defense,
and that is their attempt to evade arrest.
When there's evidence
the defendant tried to run away
or escape after they
were accused of a crime,
or police attempt to make an arrest,
that can be used against the defendant
in court as proof that
they had consciousness of guilt.
After the prosecutor announced
the parents would be charged,
the parents withdrew $4,000
and hid in a Detroit warehouse.
The Crumbley's lawyer said
that they were not fleeing from police
and they left town because
of violent threats.
Although their lawyer said
the couple was preparing
to turn themselves in,
the circumstances of their capture
don't look good.
Now, while the circumstances of this case
are unusual and no doubt
will be difficult for prosecutors,
there is some precedent
for charging parents
in somewhat similar circumstances.
In 2020, Jamelle James pleaded no contest
to involuntary manslaughter
after a six-year-old child in his home
shot and killed another
six-year-old child,
Kayla Rolland, at school.
In that case,
a witness demonstrated
how they had seen James
and another man who stayed in the house
playing with the gun,
twirling it in their hands.
Now, other adults have been charged
with involuntary manslaughter
for not securing their guns,
but prosecutors tend to charge adults
only when the shooter
was someone very young,
as in the Rolland case.
And that's because the law presumes
that children that young
can't form criminal intent,
but the same isn't true of a teenager
who can form their own criminal intent.
Teens are presumed to have agency,
which means that the chain of causation
between the adults and the homicide
is usually broken.
But there's no doubt that
this is a tragic situation.
And it's because of things like this
that I think about trying to do
the most good in this world.
And I've long been a supporter
of effective altruism.
And today's sponsor GiveWell
makes that a reality
because GiveWell spends over
20,000 hours each year
researching charitable organizations
and only recommends a few of
the highest impact,
evidence-based charities
that they found.
Over 50,000 donors have used GiveWell
to donate more than $750 million
and ensure that their donations
made the maximum impact
to save tens of thousands of lives
and improve the lives
of millions of others.
And here's the best part.
GiveWell is completely free.
It helps you allocate
tax deductible donations
to the charity that you choose
without taking a cut.
They publish all of their research
and recommendations on
their site for free,
no sign up required.
And when you donate through GiveWell,
your donations are still tax deductible
in the United States.
GiveWell's top recommendation
is to donate to their maximum impact fund,
which directs donations
to the charity or charities
that GiveWell has determined
to be the most effective each quarter.
And GiveWell is completely transparent
about how their donations are spent
and how their decisions are made.
They even have a webpage
devoted to sharing the mistakes
they've made along the well.
And it simplifies the process of finding
and giving to outstanding charities
because they do the independent research.
GiveWell gives me the peace of mind
that my donations are doing
the maximum good.
They do the evidence-based research
that I would want to do
if I had the time.
And this is incredible.
GiveWell is matching donations
from first-time donors dollar for dollar
up to $250.
All you have to do is
click on the link that's
onscreen right now
or in the description to donate
and be sure to use the fundraiser code
LegalEagle at checkout
to make sure that your
donation gets matched.
Again, to have up to $250 matched,
just click on the link
and use the code LegalEagle.
And while you're there,
click on this playlist
with all my other Real Law Reviews
for more legal analysis
of the most important legal news.